crash auf dem kudamm in berlin
charlottenburg gegen halb zehn uhr
abends krachte ein schwarzer bmw in
einen kleinwagen in dem mutter und
tochter saßen ihr fahrzeug überschlug
sich beide wurden schwer verletzt
eine der verletzten musste wiederbelebt
werden die feuerwehr war mit 36 helfern
vor ort ein fahrzeug lag auf dem dach
ersthelfer haben versucht das fahrzeug
aufzurichten es wurde dann schon im
ersten eintreffenden kräften
aufgerichtet und die dort befindliche
person befreit ist außergewöhnlicher dem
unfall sicherlich die unfall mechanik
fahrzeug sehr starker form
was doch auch eine gewisse energie bei
dem aufprall schließen lässt
trümmerteile flogen meterweit durch die
gegend und verletzten zwei passanten
auch drei weitere fahrzeuge wurden
beschädigt eine autobatterie wurde 100
meter vom unfallort entfernt gefunden
der unfallfahrer flüchtete nach
bild-informationen mit einem beifahrer
und eine beifahrerin ein augenzeuge
berichtete dass es sich um ein illegales
autorennen gehandelt habe die polizei
ermittelt wegen versuchten totschlags
und am kudamm jetzt für uns matthias
lukaschewitsch
wir haben gerade die erschreckenden
bilder aus der nacht gesehen und gehört
die täter sind zu fuß geflüchtet wie
läuft die fahndung momentan im moment
ermittelte die polizei den ganzen guten
tötungsdelikt kein wunder wenn man sieht
wie die autos zusammengeschoben worden
die wucht des aufpralls war enorm die
täter sind erwacht das muss man leider
sagen weiter flüchtig es ist natürlich
schlimm wenn man sich überlegt ein auto
fest
gewissermaßen ein anderes man lässt
einfach die opfer liegen
es ist einfach angebliche forum im
rahmen der täter die eigentlich zum
himmel schreit muss man einfach zu gern
jetzt ist das ganze wieder am kudamm
passiert nicht das erste mal dass es ein
unfall aufgrund von überhöhter
geschwindigkeit oder sogar im illegalen
autorennen gekommen ist warum immer
wieder auf dieser bekannten straße hier
in der hauptstadt
ja weil natürlich die jungen männer
diesmal leider sind die piloten die
autopiloten die quest piloten und die
zwei treffer
es sind meist junge männer irgendwie
wollen dominieren die wahnsinnigen
zeigen profilierungs fahrten machen mit
diesen dicken großen limousinen man wird
sich
überlegen der unfallwagen der 7 entweder
an 750 in hamburg angemietet ist in
zweieinhalb bis drei tonnen schwer und
der wird hier mit 400 ps hof gejagt über
den kudamm
ja man wird sich zeigen aber man darf
nicht vergessen wir stehen hier an einer
stelle mitten in der city west am kudamm
ein restaurant ist hier neben mir
gestern abend saßen die menschen um halb
zehn ist es nur dem zufall geschuldet
dass der wagen der bmxer zusagen nicht
in die irgendwie zu indira zur raum
besucher gefahrlos matthias
lukaschewitsch für diese neuen einblicke
dankeschön